welcome to exploring computing
today's video is computer networks part
one
hardware so we've been looking at
individual computers
and how individual computers work but
one of the things that makes computers
extremely useful particularly given her
current situation
is the fact that they're all working
together on the network
and so we're going to start by looking
at computer network hardware
and then we're going to take a look at
how to identify computers on the network
and then we're going to move
up to the different rules that regulate
how networks work together
and then finally we're going to end by
talking about how the worldwide web
works
and so this is going to take several
different lectures
but for starts let's take a look at the
actual physical way that computers are
hooked together
to form a network so when i'm
going to form a network of computers i
need to worry about two different things
i need to worry about what the network
topology is which is to say
what is the geometric configuration of
computers and then i need to worry about
what medium i'm using to connect the
computer together
so that's talking about like are the
computers being hooked together using
electromagnetic waves am i using optical
cables am i using
copper fiber what specific medium am i
using to connect these computers
together
here are three different classic
topologies and there are many many more
these are just three classic examples
so i've got a star network a ring
network and a bus network
you can see that the star network has a
single node in the middle and then a
bunch of nodes on the outside and
actually
you are all quite familiar with this
network because it turns out that this
particular network
is the type of network that wi-fi uses
so if you kind of think about it
you've got a bunch of people in your
house or you've got a couple people in
the classroom
and they're all on the internet and
somewhere in that room
or in the nearby room is the wi-fi
router
and so all the computers talk to that
individual wi-fi router
and if the individual wi-fi router goes
down nobody can talk to each other
so that's a star network a ring network
as you can see here we have a bunch of
computers and they're all hooked
with one following the next following
the next following the next
and so depending upon how many nodes you
have
this actually takes less connection
medium than our star network does
ring networks are commonly used for
example with optical cables
one of the problems with the ring
network at least is the way they
typically work
is if one of the nodes goes down
this messages stop traveling around the
ring you can certainly imagine
having a ring where if one of the nodes
went down the messages started going in
the opposite direction but that's not
typically how they work
and then finally our last example here
is the bus network and on a bus network
all the computers are connected to a
common cable this sort of network
used to be quite common connecting
computers together say in a classroom
bus networks also have their own set of
problems and
in fact each of these networks is going
to have to have different rules for
how they govern and how they work and so
one of the problems with the bus network
is
if multiple computers on the network try
to send out a signal at the same time
you have a problem where there's
contention on the line and the network
needs to have rules for
what happens when two computers are
simultaneously trying to use that
that bus so one question we can ask
ourselves is
what kind of we so we've seen three
different types of networks here
what kind of network is the internet
and that actually turns out to be a trip
question because
the internet is not a single network it
is actually
a network composed of different networks
so this is what we refer to as an
internetwork
and so here i've got a drawing of a
network of networks
this is the sort of thing that might
connect different people on campus
so you know we might have a set of
optical fiber cables connecting the
different
buildings in the university and so
we've got like a ring connecting each of
those
and then we might go from there to a bus
network connecting
different floors on a particular
building
and then those individual floors might
have their own bus networks so we have a
bus network connect to a bus network
and ultimately for convenience somewhere
on that bus network
we need to have our wi-fi router and
then we have different people connected
into the wi-fi router
so this is just a small example of an
internetwork but in fact
the internet itself is composed like
this with different networks connected
to different networks connected to
different networks
now there's different types of hardware
you may run into
when we're working with our
internetworks
and so one of the devices is a bridge
and a bridge is used to connect
two different networks that are of the
same type so you can imagine this is
simpler than connecting
different networks of different types
and so
say we have one bus network that's
running across all the
dorms in a particular complex so say
we have a bus connecting all the dorms
in stern or all the dorms in flomo
and then each of the individual houses
might have their own network
and so we would need a bridge to connect
one of those networks to the other
network
if we have two different types of
networks connected together we need a
fancier piece of equipment
and so a router connects two different
types of networks this is probably most
famous for wireless router so if you
hear people talk about wireless router
that is a
device that connects the wireless
network the wi-fi network
to some other type of network you may
also hear the term
gateway or gateway computer a gateway
computer is a computer that
basically acts similar to a router or a
bridge it connects
different networks together the
difference being that
the router or the bridge is a very
special purpose box that
that's its only purpose in life is
handling these messages whereas
a gateway computer is a general purpose
computer that among other things
handles network traffic now we're not
going to talk too much about the
different mediums that are available
to connect our computers together you
know there's a wide range ranging from
plain old telephone service or pots
which is the traditional copper cables
used for for telephone services
ranging up to cable networks to
fiber optic cables to wi-fi to satellite
these all are different mediums and
there are different ways we can connect
the computers in our network
one of the issues that comes up though
when we're talking about different
mediums is the bandwidth and so what the
bandwidth is
what the bandwidth originally referred
to i suppose technically still does
although computer scientists tend not to
talk about it this way
is the band of frequency that's set
aside for
that particular communication to take
place
so the wider the frequency band we have
available
the more messages we can send through
computer scientists
and generally colloquially most people
refer to bandwidth as just
the speed of the network so if i have a
lot of bandwidth that means i can send a
lot of information
quickly if i don't have a lot of
bandwidth then
i can't send messages very quickly
you may also hear the terms broadband
and narrowband
narrowband basically is plain old
telephone line
and plain old telephone service or pot
as it's
technically referred to i actually think
it's kind of a cute name
pods um you know that has
very low bandwidth and we can't send
much information through it
and in fact as we saw in one of our
previous videos if we want to send a
five minute
cd song over pots it's gonna take
about five hours so that's pretty bad
the term that you'll hear more
frequently is broadband
and this just refers to something that's
not narrowband
generally these terms aren't in
widespread use anymore
except for there's a fair number of
companies that have the name broadband
in it
because it used to be really cool to be
broadband instead of narrowband
but now everybody's broadband so you
will still hear the term broadband
banding around
mostly in the names of various companies
that are out there
but that's what they're referring to
here's some more terms you might run
into
lan stands for local area network that's
a small network
so if we have a classroom we have a
bunch of computers hooked together in
that classroom
we might have a lan if you
play computer games or you have friends
that play computer games you may hear
them refer to a lan
party this is a party where people bring
their computers
and get them networked together to play
computer games
we used to do these back in the day
when stanford changed its drinking
policy at one point
we were trying to provide students with
things to do other than drink and so
one of the activities the rcc started
having lan parties for
for campus that was kind of cool you may
also hear about wide area networks these
are networks that
connect cities across continents or even
across continents you may also hear the
term
man metropolitan area network this is a
network within a city so if you have a
friend that's
saying i need to find a good man they
might be referring to
wanting to find a good guy or
they might be thinking about uh which
city they want to move to after
graduation and making sure that that
city has a good metropolitan area
network
i'll have to admit i've actually never
seen man in use in this usage other than
in network textbooks but i'm fond of
this joke so
you guys will have to put up with it
another term you might run into is hops
as we talked about earlier the internet
is not a single network it's actually a
network of networks
and so hops is referring to how many
networks
my message needs to go through in order
to get to this destination
so if if i'm trying to communicate with
a friend say at harvard
my message is going to have to go
through many hops as it goes from the
stanford networks out to
stanford's connection with the wider
internet that goes through a bunch of
internet backbone providers it goes back
out the other side to
you know to get into the harvard network
it probably has to hop through a couple
different networks at harvard
so these are all different things that
the message has to do in order to get to
this destination
and what's going to happen here is
there's a number of different things
that's going to determine how fast a
message
or data travels through the internet one
is going to be the connection
medium so if i've got like fiber optic
cable that is going to be much faster
than say plain old telephone service
pods
but the other issue that's going to
occur is every time
message traffic goes from one network to
the next network there's also going to
be delay because
whatever we're using to connect those
two networks together
needs to spend some time looking at that
message figuring out is this a message
that's supposed to be going to someone
on my network
is this getting passed to another
network how does this need to get from
this network to the other network and so
there's a delay
because this actual processing has to
take place so the more hops we go
through
the longer the message is going to take
to get there
on a related note you may hear people
referring to lag and latency
generally speaking lag refers to the
perception that the message is getting
passed very slowly
for example one of the things that i
used to do as a resident fellow was when
we were interviewing for new ras
we would sometimes interview people at
various stanford overseas being overseas
programs
and you would notice sometimes there
would be
a long lag between when you someone
spoke and when you actually heard their
words
and so this is lag this is the
appearance that the network is not doing
well
another time you'll hear the term lag is
um you know you have a friend who plays
first-person shooters and they're like
that wasn't my fault it was a lag
actually it was their fault they sucked
but the idea here is you know they tried
to move their character in a particular
direction
and because of the delay in network
traffic
they ended up getting shot it wasn't
because they didn't move quickly enough
it was because the message
had to travel through too many slow
connections or too many hops
or there's just too much we'll talk
about this next lecture there was too
much too many other packets traveling
through the same network
um anyway so the end result was um
the information that they moved did not
get to the server in time
the term latency generally is a slightly
more technical term referring to the
amount
of delay involved in the transmission
but these two are often used more or
less synonymously
i should mention that lag and latency
are not
necessarily directly related to the
speed of the connection and so the idea
here is you could have a lot of
bandwidth
and you could still have lag and latency
and so here's an example here
suppose we are sending a message from
earth
to a spaceship traveling around mars
okay we've got several different things
that we need to think about here
you know how much bandwidth do we have
like let's say i'm
sending a new copy of the latest movie
out
i don't know i guess there aren't any
movies out right now but let's let's
pretend mulan is out
and i've got an astronaut out there and
she really loves mulan
uh she loves the cartoon version of
mulan and the new live live-action
version of mulan is out and we want to
send to her a copy and she's out of mars
so if we have
slow bandwidth it is going to take a
long time for that entire movie to reach
this destination
regardless of how far away that person
is so
let's say two of us are on the same
network there's no hops between us but
we're connected by a plain old telephone
line
it's going to take a long time for that
movie
to transmit over that telephone line
on the other hand if we have a really
fast connection because this person's
really close to us
it's going to transfer very quickly now
let's look at the situation we're
sending
the data to mars
regardless of how much bandwidth we have
it is still going to take a very long
time
for those first bits to reach mars and
if we have high bandwidth
once those first bits reach mars the
rest of the bits will follow very
quickly
if we have low bandwidth we still have
the same delay because
you know it just takes a certain amount
of time for
light to travel to mars but
if we've got a low bandwidth once those
bits start reaching mars they're going
to have to wait a long time between when
the first bit hits there and when the
last bit hits there
so the point of this is there's
different issues involved here
it's not just a matter of hey i have
really high bandwidth connection or i
have a really low bandwidth connection
yes those are important but there's also
a question of
how far away is this person how many
hops does this have to go through
and things like that and that's actually
going to be an issue
when you start worrying about things
like web servers um
we typically don't get into this but uh
you know since i've got a captive
audience here
one of the issues that comes up is if
i've got
a web server and that web server is say
in california
and my customer is in australia
there's a pretty long delay where
the message needs to get transferred
from
my server here in california through a
whole bunch of hops to get to australia
and so a better way to handle this is to
use something called a content delivery
network or cdn
and what a cdn does is it takes the
files that would normally be
in my server here in california and it
distributes to a whole bunch of
different servers around the world
so there will be a server in australia
or oceana there will be a server in say
asia there will be server in europe and
they'll be serving in the united states
there'll be server in africa
and wherever the person is trying to
access
our information from they will get it
from the near server
and so you know there will be fewer hops
to get to that server
there will be less lag there will be
less latency and the information will
get to them much faster so
if you're going to come up with a server
and you think that you're going to have
a global audience
contracting out to content delivery
network might be a great idea
all right so that's it for now in the
next lecture we're going to talk about
how to identify individual computers on
the network
and the next lecture on friday we're
going to talk take a look at
different protocols that are used
governing how information travels
through the internet
i'll see you again soon